POLICE SAY THAT HE HAS NOT YET
POSTED BAIL HE HAS REMAINED JAIL
AT THIS MOMENT.
AND PROGRESSIVE POLICIES GETTING
CALLED OUT FOR THE CRIME WAVE
RIPPING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
DEMOCRAT NEW YORK CITY
MAYOR ERIC ADAMS PUTTING THE
PRESSURE ON WOKE LOSS TO PUT
DANGEROUS CRIMINALS BACK ONTO
THE STREET.
>> MAJOR MISTAKES MADE
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS THAT
DESTROYED THE TRUST THAT THE
POLICE COMMISSIONER IS TALKING
ABOUT, WITH A REBUILD THAT
TRUST.
BUT WE CANNOT REBUILD THAT TRUST
BY ALLOWING THOSE WHO ARE
DANGEROUS AND THAT HAVE A
REPEATED HISTORY OF VIOLENCE
CONTINUE TO BE ON OUR STREETS.
>> Dana: WERE HEADING INTO THE
SUMMER OPTICS AND CRIME IN
SUMMER AS WELL.
THE MAYOR SAYS ON THE SUNDAY
SHOW WING INTO THE SUMMER HE IS
A POINT TO MAKE.
SIDE WITH THE VICTIMS AND THE
PEOPLE OF THE CITY AND WANT
SECURITY, OR WITH THESE WOKE
DEMOCRATS.
>> Greg: WE WENT FROM CRIME
HAS RISEN.
I DID LIKE THAT?
YES, IT TOOK ME TWO HOURS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT CRIME IT'S ABOUT,
CRIME AND GO DOWN IF HE STOPPED
LETTING THE PEOPLE OUT THERE
WERE COMMITTING THE CRIME.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'VE RUN
INTO THIS PROBLEM WHEN WE LOOK
AT EVERY SUSPECT IN THESE CRIMES
AND THEY HAVE JUST A PAPER TRAIL
AND THEN YOU START TO THINK, AND
ALL OF THESE RAINS OF SOCIETY
WHETHER IT'S CRIME OR EDUCATION.
THE BORDER, THERE'S A REJECTION
OF STRUCTURE AND PROCESS.
WE SHOULD BE OKAY WITH THAT BUT
THEN WE STARTED TALKING ABOUT
THE SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS, WE
STARTED TAKING APART THESE
PROCESSES AND THAT'S REALLY BAD
FOR SOCIETY THAT NATURALLY
DECAYS, WERE ALREADY GET OLDER.
THINGS FALL APART, THAT'S WHY
YOU HAVE PRISONS IN YOUR FLAWS
GIVE BORDERS YOU'VE STANDARDS.
AN HOUR BASELY SAYING THAT THE
SAME SENSIBLE RULES AND LAWS
THAT WE HAVE FOR EVERYBODY ARE
NOW IT NOT EVERYBODY BECAUSE WE
HAVE SYSTEMIC BIGOTRY, THE
SYSTEMIC RACISM WE ELIMINATED
INCENTIVES FOR CRIME AND CRIME
GOES UP.
SO YOU HAVE SOMEBODY WHO IS NOW
SHOOTING SUSPECT WAS UNDER HOUSE
ARREST.
YOU'VE ELIMINATED ONE INCENTIVE
WHICH IS PRISON.
IT MIGHT NOT BE SUCH A BAD THING
TO COMMIT CRIME IF THE WORST
AREA TO GET MISSING IN HER HOME
WITH HER ANKLE BRACELET.
SETS THE ISSUE, THE ISSUE HERE
IS THAT WE ARE DISMANTLING THE
THING THAT SOCIETY DESPERATELY
NEEDS TO HOLD US TOGETHER.
>> Dana: WHAT A THING ABOUT
THE DECISION TO GRANT BAIL AT
$25,000 AN ANKLE MONITOR OPTION?
>> IT'S ABSURD IT'S A REFLECTION
OF WHAT WE ARE AS A SOCIETY.
GREG IS TALKING ABOUT THE
ILLUMINATION OF THE
DISINCENTIVES.
WHAT WERE SEEING NOW DURING THE
HOLIDAYS YOU SEE CRIME SEARCH
AMONG FAMILY MEMBERS.
AND THE SUMMER YOU SEE, THE
STREETS AMONG GANG MEMBERS.
BUT TODAY BASED UPON WHAT THE
LEFT IS DONE IN THE SO-CALLED
SOCIAL JUSTICE AGENDA.
>> Jeanine: LIKE THE ONE IN
SOUTH CAROLINA, CLUB SHOOTING IN
SOUTH CAROLINA AND THEN IN IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
OR TALK ABOUT TEN PEOPLE SHOT,
11 PEOPLE SHOT, THIS KID GETTING
OUT HOUSE MONITOR WITH AN ANKLE
BRACELET.
YOU SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
YOURSELF.
WHOEVER THE JUDGES SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF HERSELF OR HIMSELF.
WHAT WE HAVE IS PROGRESSIVE
POLICIES THAT ARE DESTROYING
THIS COUNTRY.
AND THE TRUTH IS THAT IS THE
DELIBERATE RELEASE OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHO GO OUT AND
COMMIT CRIME BECAUSE THEY HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED BY THE LACK OF
CONSEQUENCE THAT WE HAVE CREATED
WITH THE SOCIAL JUSTICE AGENDA.
THERE IS NOW MORE OF AN INTEREST
IN THE CRIMINAL THAN THE VICTIM
AND I FEEL LIKE A BROKEN RECORD
I KEEP SAYING THAT.
IT'S ABOUT THE VIOLENT AMONG US
AND TRY TO MAKE THEM BETTER,
WHEN THE TRUTH IS THAT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IS MAKING SOCIETY
WORSE.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S ONLY TO
GET WORSE AS PEOPLE COME INTO
THE BORDER, THEY TALK ABOUT WILL
TALK ABOUT THIS LATER ON
TERRORIST LIST.
THERE'S SO MANY DON'T GET CAUGHT
AND THEY SEE WHAT'S GOING ON
THEY SEE AMERICANS ARE BEING
HELD ACCOUNTABLE WHY SHOULD THEY
APPEAR FOR THE AMERICAN DREAM A
LOT OF THEM ARE WORKING HARD.
BUT WHAT WE'VE GOT IS A MESSAGE
THAT WE HAVE SENT TO 300 MILLION
PEOPLE IT'S OKAY IF YOU SEE YOUR
NEIGHBORS YOU WANT SOMETHING IN
IT YOU WANT THE CAR, IF YOU FEEL
SOMEWHAT AN ACTIVITY TO GET AWAY
WITH IT.
>> Dana: THERE AT THAT
PROSECUTOR ON WE COULD PLAY THAT
PLEASE?
>> I'VE HAD ONE CONVERSATION
WITH THEM THOUSANDS FIRST WEEK
IN OFFICE WE HAD MUTUAL CONCERN
ON A CASE OR PARTICULAR CASE.
HIS PREDECESSOR MOVEMENT EVERY
THREE MONTHS I MET HER IN HER
OFFICE SHE MET ME IN MY OFFICE.
WE SHARED CONCERNS EXACTLY WHAT
YOU SAID SETTLEMENT UNLESS YOU
COME FROM THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS
OFFICE, YOUR BLACK LIVES MATTER
ACTIVIST.
EVERYONE ELSE JUST DOESN'T EXIST
IN THIS WORLD.
>> OBJECTIVELY IT IS TERRIBLE
AND THE SHOWDOWNS ARE GOING TO
GO SHERIFF'S IN THE MAYOR'S,
THAT'S CAN BE HAPPENING AND
LIBERAL CITIES ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY CERTAINLY AS WE HEAD
INTO ANOTHER STATE OF ELECTIONS
OR PEOPLE MAKE BIG DECISIONS.
I THINK WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
LIBERAL COMMUNITY IS THAT PEOPLE
FEEL BETRAYED BY THESE PEOPLE
THAT WE ELECT TO BE AMBASSADORS
FOR VALUES.
SOME ZONE WHO BELIEVES IN SECOND
CHANCES I RATHER SOMEONE WHO CAN
GET CAN
GET BACK ON THE STREET AND THEY
CANNOT DO IT AGAIN.
BUT WHEN PEOPLE ARE CONTINUALLY
LETTING YOU DOWN IN THIS WAY
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THE OFFICIAL
SLEEP AND ARE THE PROBLEM YOU
THOUGHT HAD THE SAME VALUES AS
YOU.
GET IT.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE EVENTUALLY
START THE MICRO STOP SHOWING UP
FOR ELECTIONS IN THE MINUTES ARE
ON WHO THEY VOTE FOR TINA TAKE
THE UPPER WEST SIDE VOTE FOR
REPUBLICAN.
IT DOES EVEN OPPORTUNITY TOUGH
CONVERSATIONS THE DEMOCRATS AND
A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF ANSWERS FOR IT TO
BE INTERESTING TO SEE IF
REPUBLICANS CAN COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS THEMSELVES IN A BULL
CITIES ARE L.A. RED.
BUT WHAT YOU GONNA DO ABOUT IT
IF YOU'RE SOMEONE WHO DOES HAVE
A DIFFERENT POINT OF VIEW OF THE
THINGS OF THESE POLICIES ARE
REALLY PUTTING PEOPLE IN DANGER
I HAVEN'T SEEN THAT.
>> EVERY TIME REPUBLICAN TRIES
TO POSITION THEMSELVES TO PAINT
THEM AS RACIST OR INTOLERANT AS
A ONE PARTY SYSTEM IN NEW YORK
REPUBLICAN FATHERS DEVOTED TO
MARKETS IS NO WAY.
THERE'S NO OTHER OPPOSITION
BECAUSE THE OPPOSITION IS
ESSENTIALLY SMEARED AT EVERY
OPPORTUNITY.
>> EVERYONE IS MEANT AS A
COMMUNIST.
I'M IN THE NAME-CALLING
OBVIOUSLY THE REAL ISSUES BECOME
A TREMENDOUS PROBLEM.
>> Jeanine: THE PARENTS WHO
REACH OUT TO PEOPLE IN SALMON
CISCO WHO CAN'T GET AN ANSWER
HOW RELEASED AND CONVICTED
MURDERERS WITHOUT TELLING THE
VICTIMS THAT ARE COMING OUT,
THOSE OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CALLING OUT THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Dana: LUCY OR THE PEOPLE
WHO'VE LOST THEIR KIDS TO
GUN VIOLENCE THAT IF YOU LIKE
THEY'RE BEING LISTENED TO BY
THEIR REPUBLICAN PARTY AT ALL.
>> Jeanine: TO THE COME TO GO
TO JAIL?
THEN SHE FEEL LIKE SHE WAS TO
LISTEN TO OKAY COME UP WITH THE
CRIMINAL WENT TO JAIL.
AND THUS THE JOB.
>> I LOOK AT DAs AND JUDGES
SHERIFFS ARE ALL ELECTED BY
PEOPLE.
THIS IS A DEMOCRACY AND WE HAVE
PEOPLE IN L.A. AND NEW YORK WERE
WOKE LIBERAL OFFICIALS WHO
COMMIT THESE POLICIES AND WERE
OUTRAGED BY THE CRIME THAT
HAPPENS WITH THE POLICIES BUT
REALLY PEOPLE WHO ASKED FOR THE
POLICIES BECAUSE THEY VOTED FOR
THESE FOLKS TO TAKE THE POSITION
OF POWER SO WHAT DO YOU WANT TO
CHANGE THE NARRATIVE VIEW OF THE
CHANGE ELECTED OFFICIAL AND WITH
REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS.
I DON'T CARE WHO I JUST WANT
SOMEONE ONE LAST POINT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THESE POLICIES THAT HAVE
CHANGED OVER THE COURSE THE LAST
2-3 YEARS EXPLOSION OF CRIME.
THIS WOULD'VE HAPPENED 30 YEARS
AGO EXHIBIT ETHICS AND MORALS
AND VALUES WITH FAMILIES BUT
SOMETHING IS HAVEN'T YOUR POINT
WITH THE CULTURE IS BEEN A
DEGRADATION THAT WHEN YOU HAVE
LAX POLICIES WHEN YOU CAN COMMIT
A CRIME ANKLE BRACELET.
THEY NEVER WOULD'VE TOOK THE
GUN.
I SAID 30 YEARS.
>> Jeanine: I AGREE WITH YOU
CRIME WAS PR